Suppose I look at the registry
of residents of my town and
pick a person at random.
What is the probability
that this person is
under 18 years of age?
The answer is about 25%.
Suppose now that I tell you that
this person is married.
Will you give the same answer?
Of course not.
The probability of being
less than 18 years
old is now much smaller.
What happened here?
We started with some initial
probabilities that reflect
what we know or believe
about the world.
But we then acquired
some additional
knowledge, some new evidence--
for example, about this person's
family situation.
This new knowledge should cause
our beliefs to change,
and the original probabilities
must be replaced with new
probabilities that take into
account the new information.
These revised probabilities are
what we call conditional
probabilities.
And this is the subject
of this lecture.
We will start with a formal
definition of conditional
probabilities together with
the motivation behind this
particular definition.
We will then proceed to develop
three tools that rely
on conditional probabilities,
including the Bayes rule,
which provides a systematic
way for incorporating new
evidence into a probability
model.
The three tools that we
introduce in this lecture
involve very simple and
elementary mathematical
formulas, yet they encapsulate
some very powerful ideas.
It is not an exaggeration to
say that much of this class
will revolve around the repeated
application of
variations of these three
tools to increasingly
complicated situations.
In particular, the Bayes rule
is the foundation for the
field of inference.
It is a guide on how to
process data and make
inferences about unobserved
quantities or phenomena.
As such, it is a tool that is
used all the time, all over
science and engineering.